[Musik]
die wollen auf und davon birgit und
jackson haben kinder großgezogen jetzt
ziehen sie los auf die philippinen
die familie fischer aus dem aargau
wünscht sich mehr lebensqualität
sie bricht auf in die weite kanadas vom
asl ans mittelmeer
monika und bert daniela folgen ihrem
traum
sie bauen ein kleines hotel in der
türkei
[Musik]
jeder dachte wohl schon einmal daran weg
zu gehen alles hinter sich zu lassen
irgendwo auf dieser welt von neuem zu
beginnen
doch vielen fehlt der mut und nur wenige
brechen wirklich auf
[Musik]
familie fischer hat sich entschieden sie
will nach kanada auswandern
doch wer los zieht muss bereit sein lieb
gewonnenes loszulassen am jugendfest den
stoffen läuft töchterchen christin am
kinderumzug mit zum ersten und
gleichzeitig letzten mal geschafft
ja so ein mitglied
[Musik]
wie einst der vater läuft heute sohn
pauli am umzug mit doch der scheint
keine lust auf erinnerungsfotos zu haben
die ganze familie fischer kann das
jugendfest nur halbwegs genießen denn
eigentlich möchte sie schon seit langem
nicht mehr hier in staufen sein
das ganze dorf weiß die familie fischer
will auswandern
und es weiß auch die fischers haben ein
problem sich zum auswandern zu
entschließen ist eine sache das
notwendige visum zu erhalten eine ganz
andere
seit drei jahren bemühen sich die
fischers um ein visum für kanada der 37
jährige kurt ist zimmermann und hat
bereits einen arbeitsvertrag bei einem
kanadischen blockhausbau abgeschlossen
das mitgefühl vieler dorfbewohner ehrt
die fischers zwar aber einfacher macht
es ihrer situation nicht im gegenteil
[Musik]
das größte problem momentan aber wir
verstehen tag so um ein gefragt so sind
ist wieder da wo sie langsam besser
warum probieren wir diese idee zu ihrer
die fischers lieben den aargau und
fühlen sich mit dem dorf verbunden
trotzdem ihre kinder pulli und christin
möchten sie in kanada aufziehen
sie wollen endlich abreißen
[Musik]
ob wie con im zürcher unterland
wohnungsräumung bei birgit und jux hin
jedes einzelne buch doch das papier ist
im raum wenig effizient merck abschied
bedeutet auch liebgewordene
vorstellungen loszulassen und die
verstecken sich mitunter in den
kleinsten dingen dann waren sie sind 50
kilo ersteigert das sieht immer für
meine enkel zu bauen
seit die kinder ausgezogen sind ist es
bei den science ruhig geworden in dieser
stelle erinnert sich das ehepaar an
ihren alten traum den traum auszuwandern
auf der philippinischen insel palawan
soll er nun wahr werden
dort bauen sie ein ferien resort und so
ziehen bei den sens die eltern in die
ferne
die jungen die 23 jährige lea und ihr
drei jahre älterer bruder ihren bleiben
in der schweiz zurück viel altes muss
weg wenn ein neuer weg eingeschlagen
wird der 52 jährige informatiker jörg
fährt zur müllsammelstelle
also darf aber jetzt verhindern
ja auch wir die zusage zu 15 prozent
rechnen in öko ware die sie in ihrem
neuen leben direkt am meer nicht mehr
brauchen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ein herbsttag im appenzellerland
[Musik]
aber wohin wir gehen dort gibt es leider
keine auf dem barfußweg in gonten spüren
monika und der türkischstämmige wörtern
noch einmal schweizer boden unter den
füßen
monica ist eine waschechte appenzellerin
und liebt ihre heimat auch wörtern hat
die denn sieben jahren die er hier wohnt
die schweiz lieb gewonnen
[Musik]
ich suche mir das auch natürlich die
heimat ja ja ja wir hatten so vermisste
grünen werden wir wissen das kann schon
sagen es gehen wir schon die beiden
haben sich in der türkei kennengelernt
burton war manager eines großen
hotelbetriebes monika war reiseleiterin
aber sprechen so dass nicht alle
probiere das ehepaar führt hier ein
sicheres und angenehmes leben und doch
tiefes glück stellte sich nie ein
es hat immer etwas gefällt ihnen bei uns
beide wenn es winter ist da sind wir
beide fast stumm zu hause sie hat keine
lust zu sprechen ich habe keine lust zum
sprechen weil alltag arbeiten wir
schaffen wir wenn es wochenende ist
haben wir den stress mit einkaufen
wäsche waschen haus reinigen und zweiter
dann hast du nur einem sonntag und am
sonntag möchtest du ja wissen aussuchen
weil ich habe drei schicht gearbeitet
das war ein bisschen hart und es hat
immer gefehlt bei uns so eine sehr
ungern her ich das appenzellerland immer
wieder habe im modernen ferien als ich
von missio hat und von dem her
die kommende saison
an der türkischen mittelmeerküste wollen
sie noch einmal von vorn beginnen und
ein hotel bauen
nur noch wenige tage bis zur
auswanderung der g10 beschäftigt dass
sie die eltern losziehen und die kinder
zurücklassen
das bliebe die nicht irgendeins klappfix
gewerbe aber ich mache das gutachten ist
kurz gefühl gibt ja noch ferien einmal
im jahr am max eyth der körper seine
zahlen um drei mal im jahr musste der so
viele leute das so sagt sie und für
richtig
die qualitativ viel intensiver raus was
man bisher also hoffentlich sind die
gipfel hingegen möchte sie auch in ihrer
neuen heimat auf der philippinischen
insel palawan button
als künftige betreiberin eines
ferienresorts wie sie ihre gäste mit
schweizer backwaren fahnen der mensch
schiebt die erfüllung seiner träume oft
vor sich hier bis es plötzlich zu spät
zu werden droht manchmal findet er erst
dann die kraft umzusetzen was er sich
immer wünschte 20 seiten das wäre mal
etwas mit aufbauen so dass immer neue
seeler und hamburger das haben wir den
opfern ins dorf und das in quinto und
und dann haben wir das risiko und dann
sind wir seit 23 jahren die man sieht
man immer wieder haben sondern und den
hauptweg und sich immer stärker dem
spieltag sie natürlich einfach dank
sabine minister jahre lang haben wir
gegen die regel für das wandern und
besonders machen kriegt und jetzt und
jetzt heißt impfwilligen die gleichung
der golf möglich dass dann jedoch und
bin ich noch zwei drei tage möglich und
roh und youngster sie handlich sein mit
denen ist das noch immer die kommentare
bekannt und ob es ist ganz sicher nie
bösartig und soweit ich weiss nicht mehr
dem urteil haftet wenn nicht irgendwann
uhr spielt auch sie will es zu
verspätungen können
die kündigung hat seine frau birgit
ebenfalls hinter sich die ehemalige
schulleiterin geht ein letztes mal auf
das sekretariat ihre schul kreises der
g10 trug verantwortung für 300 kinder
und gut 50 lehrpersonen
sie kennt die unwägbarkeiten des lebens
und sie hat gelernt vorauszuschauen sie
will abgesichert sein
als vorläufer für das profiteam des
albums 10 ist weder mit der blauen
ermittler
zum abschied hat birgit ihren kollegen
die selbst gebackenen gipfeli
mitgebracht also das sind jetzt die gibt
für die oder und ihr sind jetzt mini day
statt die erste offizielle
in staufen im kanton aargau ist der
briefkasten leer geblieben
die fischers banken noch immer um ihr
visum
kurt ist selbstständiger zimmermann und
hat eine werkstatt
jetzt löst er sie auf die maschinen
nimmt er mit nach kanada für den zoll
schreiben sie eine materialliste die
werkstatt ist mit ein grund warum die
fischers auswandern wollen bald wäre der
ein-mann-betrieb nicht mehr
konkurrenzfähig er hätte erneuert werden
müssen
aufsteller groß machen oder das nicht
der wiederaufbau der größe her und dann
im studio sofort keine ordentliche
millionen dollar
und da muss muss sich damit nach liebe
triebe nicht haben statt sie ja wieder
erwirtschaften und das ich mir einfach
deutlich wer auf dem durch klagen ja
deshalb bin ich häufig kulturverein
blick bedeutet wenn wir wenn man bruder
vergrößert habe der oder und und die
familie die er 15 ist das ganz klar und
von dem ich mich sehr sehr noch ein
betrag stetig und samstag sonntag 3 das
cool
jahrelang arbeitete kurz während sechs
tagen pro woche und abends wenn die
kinder im bett waren kümmerte er sich
noch um den papierkram
nun nimmt er seit wochen keine neuen
aufträge mehr an
sie haben übel auch annett hat ihre
stelle als lehrerin an einer
landwirtschaftsschule bereits aufgegeben
da stellt man auch die hochblüte aber
wir sehen die zum ruhme medien scharfe
auflösung ist die sache könnte und wenn
sie es plötzlich heißt nico ich weiß
nicht ob die täter davon
also wie selbstständiger werden wenn das
mit dem visum mittel glaubt mehr an die
zu so viel energie in der letzten
periode sind mit so viel energie steckt
und wenn die zwölf musiker ich weiß
nicht wieso muss ich mich recht 04
[Musik]
in herisau befindet sich der hauptsitz
eines internationalen unternehmens der
elektroindustrie als berta nur sonja
lila der liebe wegen in die schweiz kam
fand er hier in der kabelbinder arbeit
dann hat sich hochgearbeitet am schluss
war er leiter eines 25 köpfigen teams
fernab seiner heimat hat der türke
beruflichen erfolg und glück in der
liebe gefunden heute nun feiert er
seinen abschied was immer der 39-jährige
anpackt er wie das gut machen
deshalb ist er heute besonders nervös
werthan ist beliebt im unternehmen
die strenge arbeit im schichtbetrieb
müssen seine kollegen nun bald ohne ihn
erledigen
ich freue mich dass er so zahlreich zu
meinem abschied sapporo erschienen sind
ich und meine frau werden endlich unser
traum in der türkei verwirklichen wir
werden ein kleines boutique hotel bauen
deswegen müssen wir jetzt schon weg
reisen und dort seien wegen den
bauarbeiten wie es läuft und so weiter
weil wir möchten dass nächstes jahr im
juni schon eröffnen
und ich wünsche euch alles gute
doch bevor er gehen kann muss ja noch
eine letzte prüfung bestehen und darum
immer der noch also organisiert ist da
wegen weg gehen und es war einmal ein
brief verschicken aber maximal zu erst
dann werde ich mal schauen wie sie es
sehen würde dass funktionäre
[Musik]
trotz der freude am appenzeller
brauchtum bertrand zieht es zurück in
seiner heimat
dort will er noch einmal ein neues leben
beginnen und dieses neue leben bietet
keinen platz für ein altes laster nicht
mehr rauchen aufhören weil wir werden
nach zu zeigen wo meine familie auch
niemand deswegen werde das auch für uns
leicht sein wird
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
schlechte neuigkeiten für die fischers
ihr visumsantrag wurde erneut
zurückgewiesen
die heutige gute nacht geschichte fällt
kurz aus
die fischers wurden noch dieser nacht
einen neuen antrag stellen
sie sind unter druck sie brauchen
endlich ihr visum kurz kanadische
arbeitgeber hatte vergessen ein formular
mit zu schicken
wegen dieses kleinen formfehlers wird
sich die abreise der familie fischer um
einen weiteren monat verzögern schon
viel zu viele abende verbrachten sie vor
dem computer haben formular um formular
ausgefüllt
irgendwann so hoffen sie wird die
bürokratie besiegt sein und ihr traum
wahr werden
und da hast du in der schweiz
dieses mal muss es klappen
der dritte antrag soll perfekt werden
[Musik]
im zürcher unterland erwarten die sens
besuch heute will das ehepaar seine
eigentumswohnung vermietet
eine gruppe junger leute steht vor der
tür
sens wohnung soll eine studentenbude
werden die wohnung ist zweistöckig hat
sechs zimmer und ist 220 quadratmeter
groß mit dem mietzins erlös finanzieren
die sense unter anderem das studium
ihres sohnes noch ist der traum der
sense zwischen zwei buchdeckeln
eingeklemmt das grundstück mehr besitzen
sie bereits dass ferien resort muss doch
gebaut werden
der 26-jährige sohn jan wirth
statthalter seiner eltern in der schweiz
und verwaltet die wohnung länger bewusst
und das jetzt der schrittweise team
dankt oder rhedes taktiken mittelstand
sehen oder wie viele dinge ich wieder
grundsätzlich finde ich sagen ich finde
es wirklich so etwas machen
aber nicht nur das rausholen vor acht
studiert sage durch das legitim so dass
ich allein im internet verzichten
aber ich könnte mir irgendwer irgendwo
niveau seit des kantersiegs wie ist und
64 braucht wenig und ich habe für das
sind nette junge mannschaft
[Musik]
tief in der nacht beginnt monikas und
burtons abenteuer
sie wandern mit dem auto aus
es ist ein schwieriger abschied monikas
vater ist krank und die mutter lässt die
beiden nur ungern sind die letzten tage
haben die beiden bei monikas eltern in
herisau gewohnt die schweiz und ich
zwang zur kompletten neues leben
ich singe genau war ist erwartet ja mit
den klassischen ich muss sagen dass mit
michael mitnehmen
ich brauche halt nicht mehr nach darum
den gremien für ein zweites leben
würdest du hast ihn besuchen kommt ihrem
schirm oder jenson
[Musik]
nein nein
ich lass mal den motor ist dann mal für
alle ziemlich mit puppen
beide nicht weit kommen
ja
okay die ist da
ciao
[Musik]
alle fischer ist daran ihren dritten
visumsantrag fertigzustellen
einmal mehr pendelt die 34 jährige vom
keller büro in die küche hoch es sind
nächte wie diese in denen halt manchmal
auch leise zweifel befallen
besonders wenn sie an ihre beiden kinder
denkt auf der straße landet mit dem
spiel beschäftigt
[Musik]
planmäßig und ohne verzögerung läuft es
bei den 6 der große tag ist da ein
buntes grüppchen hat sich zum abschied
eingefunden
birgit hat allen eine rose mitgebracht
orange musste sie seien ihre
lieblingsfarbe
[Musik]
dass die mutter geht fällt der tochter
lia besonders schwer
[Musik]
ja sie ist also doch noch heftig sie
ermöglichen und sah man von sich
aber sie haben genau das sind york nur
wie von alleine
es ist erst ihr zweiter flug auf die
philippinen und dieses mal werden sie
für lange zeit nicht mehr zurückkommen
ja ich bin ja nicht so dass der
gefühlsduselig ab jetzt doch irgendwie
mögen also sony mediziner spricht aber
dass wir zu vermissen auch die euch
natürlich wie euch natürlich einige
wochen haben sie sich ob sie sich das
birgit hat eine erstes problem
die leidenschaftliche raucherin hat so
viele fahrzeuge dabei
[Musik]
eine lange reise steht den beiden bevor
17 stunden flug und zwei zwischenstopps
in 30 stunden werden sie an ziel sein
[Musik]
als schweizer
die englische küste der türkei 70
kilometer südlich von izmir liegt das
neue zuhause von monika und wärtern seit
zweieinhalb tagen sind die beiden
auswanderer unterwegs
[Musik]
im 12.000 zehlendorf alle shuttle bauen
sie ihr hotel noch nichts
ich werde das war so lassen dem auto
hier ist soll es einmal stehen ihr hotel
ihre gemeinsame zukunft ihr neues
zuhause
vor einem halben jahr haben sie das 600
quadratmeter große grundstück gekauft
taxi der bauleiter erwartet sie bereits
guten tag ich bin der bauleiter schön
sind sie da wir freuen uns auch hier zu
sein aber ich bin sicher die ganze
komisches gefühl ich bin jetzt da bricht
jetzt noch gar nicht dass familie
heimatpreis ganze komisches gefühl es
geht normal ist anders 17-mal visum
street mitten glaubte mit acht zimmer
sind geplant ein garten mit einer bar
und einem swimmingpool
alles was sie besitzen haben monika und
wörtern in dieses projekt gesteckt ihr
ganzes erspartes und die
pensionskassengelder
[Musik]
botschafter ist ein kleiner
aufstrebender ferienort mit dem auto
erreicht man in wenigen minuten eine
vielzahl strenge
[Musik]
schöne problematisch können wir mit
heißkleber ist man da so
[Musik]
ihre sehnsucht nach wärme und dem er
ließ die beiden in den süden ziehen die
strände der türkischen ägäis und nicht
appenzeller wiesen sind jetzt ihr
zuhause
ich habe telefonate
hilfe
die wurzeln schwimmen kommt es genutzt
über zu sehen
bravo nicht verlernt ja ich schön dafür
stand sich wieder zu hause
dieses mal habe ich monika dabei vorerst
wohnen die beiden am rand von al assad
gemeinsam mit wörtern schwestern und
deren ehemann haben sie ein häuschen
gemietet
[Musik]
dollar und ihr ehemann sind extra aus
istanbul angereist sie unterstützen die
beiden auswanderer während der ersten
wochen
wir schauen wir uns in die augen
[Musik]
endlich auf diesen moment haben die
fischers wochenlang gewartet die post
ist da post von der kanadischen
botschaft erhalten sie jetzt endlich ihr
visum beim dritten versuch ethisch
und dann der satz den sie nie mehr lesen
wollten ihre bewerbung ist unvollständig
der strichcode den der computer jeweils
automatisch beim ausdrucken der anträge
erstellt war für die
einwanderungsbehörde nicht lesbar eine
tragödie nicht nur für die fischers auch
für kurz kanadischen arbeitgeber dieser
erwartet nämlich dringend seinen neuen
schweizer fachmann konnte noch
kein visum keine feierstimmung
also das ganze noch einmal von vorne
zum vierten mal
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
lassen sich die fischers nicht
unterkriegen sie machen weiter und
wollen ihr haus verkaufen und die
auswanderer bekommen ein mail von der
botschaft
trotz der hilfe eines nikotinpflaster
bert dann fällt es schwer nicht zu
rauchen
denn auf der baustelle stehen bereits
die ersten probleme an ist funktioniert
nicht wen schweiz
[Musik]
auf der philippinischen insel palawan
zieht birgit zum ersten mal ihr
grundstück cabrios und der erste gast
ist auch schon da die affendame bis mai
träumen
[Musik]
sid